sonst läuft es
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja auch künstliches blut
stichflammen
vor und feuerbälle es ist projektwoche
an der zürcher privatschule kalender ich
glaube halt immer das freut wo man hat
versucht über fast wichtigste schon kann
man freude dass im tennis mehr motiviert
und dann kommt alles andere von allein
gelassen es ist für mich drauf gehabt
dass ich da natürlich nie machen wo
nicht irgendwelche formen auch sie
besonders kinder frankenberger und
ausprobieren alle kinder die hier zur
schule gehen haben etwas gemeinsam sie
sind hochbegabt das heißt sie haben
einen iq von 130 oder mir und lernen
darum viel schneller ausgleich häufig
damit ihr intellektuelles potenzial
ausschöpfen können werden sie hier
gezielt gefördert
[Musik]
michelle x10 was denn das mega die
intellektuelle überfliegerin aus dem
glarnerland ingame in den kindergarten
und freute sich auf die schule
dort begannen allerdings bald die
probleme
michelle war unterfordert und verlor das
interesse am lernen das änderte sich
erst auch sie haben die talente
wechselte was glaubt ihr denn da haben
wir ganz klar dass alles sauber macht
aber dass vor der mit grünen die die
schule und dann bist du hast ja und was
hast du gemacht dann fertig
das ist langweilig sind heute macht ihr
schule wieder spaß
[Applaus]
michelle macht in der volksschule die
hausaufgaben bei den prüfungen war sie
trotzdem immer die beste
ganz so einfach gibt es nun nicht mehr
verlieren oder gott immer nur einfach
alles kommt von der leiche vergangen
aber nicht wenn man sich wirklich nicht
ablehnen muss dass man sich die zeit da
mitzieht für die sache braucht und das
inventar
wahrscheinlich müssen lehrer dass man
mein geschichtslehrer tun
in der volksschule fehlte der sensiblen
michele nicht nur die intellektuelle
herausforderung sie waren da auch keinen
anschluss
liliana hat eine beachtete in wehr und
hat diese sache zu mit seitlich
bestreben und in maine ist denn da wird
dem motto mobil mobbing was ist dann
passiert also verschieden ist ein
anderes ende hat einfach die wichtig sei
dass jetzt das mal ändern
die sache ist einfach und ich habe mir
dass man dann probiert die andere arbeit
machen damit demselben wie truppe ist
und das hat dann halt den bemerkungen wo
sonst gemacht als angeschlagen
seit ich die sache ca
wir setzen die auch sehr viel dran
kostet die mitglieder haben ich hatte
mir hätte sich nämlich fröhliche
aufgestellt trinken sie immer ruhiger
und tory geworden ist und ich habe mir
die heiligen wie vor quasi gar kein
geistige dann hätte sie das aufgesogen
und freunde und schule ist für sie noch
schlimmer geht's gut
jakobus haben vier kinder
nach michelle kamen noch drei mädchen
inzwischen sind die drillinge fünf jahre
julia vanessa und jasmin michelle und
ihre drei schwestern verstehen sich gut
meistens jedenfalls
[Musik]
und sie sich aus kann der sport kaputt
gegangen also jetzt minister bewähren
haben wir gar nicht ran anschlag
verhehlt diese sagt lud aber das ist ja
cool will hier spiele ich spiele gern
mit denen normale probleme im leben
einer zehnjährigen sie speziell verlief
indes michelles kurze zeit in der
volksschule
sie begann zu schwänzen zog sich zurück
und ihr gemüt verdunkelte sich zusehends
für die ganze familie eine schwierige
zeit eigentlich der welt meinem johann
verhältnis ist wir haben wir noch halt
verschult pflichte ich jetzt einfach die
musik zu machen können ist eine frau
zitiert das wirkt natürlich und
ungeschminkt die jungs sitzen in der
schule haben ja nicht kastrieren also
haben wir mit großen hallen sind der
erste schritt zur lösung war dass die
wurzel des problems erkannt wurde
michelle gehört zu den zwei prozent der
bevölkerung die hochbegabt sind
schuster ist spezialisiert auf die
abklärung von hochbegabten sie verfasst
seit 20 jahren gutachten und gibt
empfehlungen ab in ihrer praxis erlebt
sie immer wieder familien die am rande
ihrer kräfte sind
dell meldete china häufig wie es eben
problem hat erklärt dass es im
kindergarten buchwert trug wie es häufig
dass die das segment zurückziehen
twitter bourbon ist es häufiger dass sie
aggressiv werden unter vertrag ist
körperlich gesehen wie ihr gift für das
kind unterforderung führt zu stress lang
andauernder stress führt zu hunted zu
körperliche symptome wenig dass sie
gangs erwähnten kopfweh buch wie
psychosomatische erkrankung sind erfolg
vor unterforderung nikolaus 12 und
hochbegabt er liebt herausforderungen
nicht nur in der schule sondern auch in
seiner freizeit regelmäßig trainiert er
bei den sportschützen und wer sich fragt
was ist mit anpassungen in regionale
wettkampf teil
das gehe ich mit anderen masse und aber
hier besteht können im irakkrieg rasch
mit dämmung sein ganz fest bevor sie
eine hochbegabung erkannt wurde viel
seinen eltern auf das er zusehends
unkonzentrierter wurde nicola war auf
müde und klagte über bauchschmerzen
seine probleme lösten sich in luft auf
als er an die talente wechseln konnte
der brite auf und plant bereits seine
zukunft also mein puls wollte ich im
moment noch steckt das wird sehr gerne
architekt werden
ich bin unter anderem um ganz anders
werden sind dann nicht dass alles
schlimm
[Musik]
michelle ist die erste die sich bei
familie jacobo am morgen auf den weg
macht
sie pendelt jeden tag vom planer land in
die stadt zürich und am abend wieder
zurück
sony ericsson am morgen dank lebenslauf
[Musik]
am anfang sei es ein komisches gefühl
gewesen michelle allein auf den langen
schulweg zu schicken erzählen die eltern
inzwischen ist das tägliche routine kann
natürlich auch immer passiert ist
passiert
im traum trifft sich eine kollegin die
sie von der schule kennt xenia
ja
bei der intelligenz spielen gene eine
große rolle
sie legen unsere intelligenz potenzial
fest
damit dieses potenzial zum tragen kommt
muss allerdings die umgebung stimmen
[Musik]
viele dieser kinder haben einen längeren
leidensweg hinter sich fühlten sich als
eine art aliens in der volksschule hier
machen sie zum ersten mal die erfahrung
keine außenseiter zu sein
es ist für dirk sind woanders sind als
extrem wichtig für die sozial
emotionalen trick dass sie immer wieder
auch mit ähnlich denken oder fühlen
hinzu kämen das kann sie dass es
außerhalb fotoschule sind also da gibt
es ja der verein für ältere für
hochbegabte kino regelmäßige so angebot
anbietet oder das spezial schule oder
das haar des pools
aber das sind wichtige es wird jemand
einfach mehr gehöre dazu und es war
normal sie ersatz danke uns fühlen
es gibt kinder die mühe haben in der
schule weil sie nicht mitkommen es gibt
aber auch ein paar wenige die mühe haben
wenn sie zu begabt sind für sie gibt es
jetzt eine lösung in der stadt zürich
beginnt ein experiment das für die
schweiz einmalig ist
hochbegabte kinder können eine eigens
für sie errichtete sonderklasse besuchen
heute war schon anfangen begonnen habe
die talente 1998 mit einem einzigen
schulzimmer und einer einzigen klasse
bestehend aus neun kindern zwischen
sieben und zehn jahren
der gegenwind aus der staatlichen
bildungs welt war erheblich dass
hochbegabte unter sich sein sollen war
vielen suspekt
über 20 jahre später hat die talente ein
eigenes schulhaus im zürcherischen kreis
6 und unterrichtete 250 kinder
das ist unser werk improvisiert aber es
funktioniert das alles kreative bewirkt
ein ordnungsfanatiker ist denn gott das
bier ist nicht einfach hier ist
studierter biologe zudem ausgebildeter
primar und gymnasiallehrer
er hat die talente gegründet und leitet
sie bis heute
er hat selber einen hochbegabten sohn
und musste feststellen dass es keine
maßgeschneiderten angebote gab sehr wohl
aber eine nachfrage das ist schulz immer
von der gruppe grünen
das sind meistens richtet 12 14 oder
zusammengefasst werden und stellen jedes
schwieriger finden als hochbegabt
nein also das ist natürlich ein ehrt uns
glauben während ältere kommen und sagen
oh mist kind so blöd in der schule das
muss hochbegabt sind
das ist einfach nicht wahr und es hat
sich eigentlich so merkmal darunter ok
in bösensell machende klasse und
enthüllt sie halt sich anders wenn er
oder sie hat halt so irgendwelche
aufmerksamkeit aber generell kann man
das so nicht sagen was man laut ihr auch
nicht sagen kann dass nun hochbegabt ist
wir beim iq test mindestens 130 punkte
erreicht
sicher es wichtig der eco test event das
von jedem kind aber es ist nicht so dass
eigentlich nur dass das entscheidend
denn ich will sie mir vorstelle sie hat
ja sehr großer streu brief den sie für
internet sage methoden der kris kommen
ist jetzt hoch begabt und 120 kommunen
oder das ist wahrlich nur den witz wenn
man die texte so nimmt er dabei nichts
fest von der naturwissenschaften prägt
das sei bisher einfach als zahlen nehmen
das können sie nicht
die talent da ist nicht mehr die einzige
schule für hochbegabte
das angebot ist gewachsen und steht quer
in der bildungslandschaft in der
pädagogik geben die befürworter ein
inklusiven beschulung den ton an
hochbegabte minderbegabte und alle
dazwischen sollen in dieselbe klasse
gehen keinen ausschließen alle
einschließen inklusion statt exklusion
für hochbegabte sollen spezielle
angebote in der volksschule reichen
ich weiß nicht ob das eine brücke
inklusion ist waren das kind denn
praktisch ex sturm der große gott und
tod sondern förderlehrer gott und das
speziell macht und da speziell macht die
kind also ich weiß dass einfach die an
zum teil probleme weil sie so zu muster
werden wenn sie tun und eigentlich alles
anders programm hand wo mit dem cluster
hat und sie sind außerhalb von douglas
zum teil
und das ist auch sinnvoll sofern alter
die talent aus andere hochbegabte ab und
bringe sie um wichtige lernen
erfahrungen im umgang mit sozialer
vielfalt argumentieren hier ist kritiker
das hat auch damit zu tun dass man in
der schweiz anstatt vor elitebildung mir
redet vom goldigen mittelberg nicht vom
goldige höhenberg und das finde ich seit
einiges über äußere schweizer mentalität
was heißt ja dadurch falle also so wie
die oder und das ist sich mit prägend
dass da leider die vier große ressource
für intellektuell begabte kinder und
erwachsene zu wenig im fokus klo werden
und jetzt brauchen noch einmal in einer
heute noch hinaus
kinder wie nicolas in der ausnahmen rund
70 prozent der hochbegabten bleibt in
der volksschule das überspringen von
klassen in kombination mit
förderprogrammen reicht meist völlig
aber es gibt offensichtlich auch kinder
die erst ihn hier so unterricht wieder
glücklich werden aber schulkonzept hat
mir danach falle und es hat einfach für
mich
wer hier zur schule gehen will braucht
intellektuelle ressourcen aber auch
finanzielle die talente ist eine
privatschule
sie kostete rund 2000 franken pro monat
wir haben ziemlich intensiv sucht noch
sponsoren
leider haben sie mir nicht fündig wurde
es ist aber so dass küsse schulgemeinden
feld übernahmen waren sie einfach gesagt
es gibt andere möglichkeiten aber es ist
sicher nicht erwünscht dass zürich habe
mehr hand kam der warme hand
räumlichkeiten wo es sehr viel geld
kostet und mehr zahlen als die
lehrkräfte sowie an der volksschule wert
auf die plätze fertig los
nur einmal zu ändern und dann lassen die
schweiz kompensiert ihren mangel an
natürlichen rohstoffen seit je mit
großen anstrengungen zur steigerung der
innovationskraft
gleichzeitig wird die begabtenförderung
eher stiefmütterlich behandelt
das große geld geht ein kind wirklich
schwächer der hand was ich absolut
die in frage stellen aber ich find es
zwei verschiedene die handkasse es sind
wirklich auf vorteil wo herrscht dass
dir hin wo rebecca hand dass sich die
begebung von anleihen gesetzt und das
das ist einfach nicht so sieht ist sie
haben andere bedürfnisse handsonde
bedürfnis und autor hans recht auf dem
quad gefördert werden und nicht nur
erkannt sondern anerkannt werden
[Musik]
nicolas zeit an der talent tag in diesen
sommer zu ende
er hat uns öffentlich gymnasium
gewechselt
[Musik]
es geht heute gang und da muss man über
tödliche schlag und hörte um aber die
muss man aber das wichtigste ich mir das
alles glücklich aber weiter und neugier
und visp gebiete führen kann und zwar in
sachen unterstützen es gern machen
nicola startet mit viel optimismus in
seinen neuen lebensabschnitt über den
wind können wir nicht bestimmen das
weiße haus angehen es gibt aber wir
können die segel richten
[Musik]
das haben wir bewiesen dass wir die
schlacht macht uns nicht gut das haben
wir einmal untersucht hallo wir haben
befindlichkeit von den globalen und das
ist absolut gut und man keine zeigen
dass innerhalb von einem halben jahr
und so sind die befindlichkeit um sehr
sehr sehr viel stellenprozenten können
verbessere
und solange das so ist ist es ja eine
genommen nicht gut
[Musik]
wir haben unsere aufgestellt die
fröhliche tochter wieder zurück wo freud
darum lehren und anrufe gestellt wie man
sogar seltener das wünscht also sicher
schlagen
ich glaube nicht dass sie extrem offen
der wechsel an die talente hat aber noch
mehr bewirkt hat michelle damit versöhnt
dass sie anders ist als die meisten
nämlich hochbegabt ist das für die ich
erinnere bis positiv so drehen lässt
es ist er indes positiv wäre es sicher
schneller lerner trainer und stade bis
verstarb
leipzig
[Musik]
dennis k